god is yoga
at church in buffalo this sunday faith
was providing solace for some
we will not be distracted
from the praise of an almighty god
for this upstate new york community this
is the hardest of moments
it is not possible for any community to
comprehend this and yet again and again
in america they are forced to
a supermarket and a car park was the
setting for this latest mass shooting 10
people shot dead most of them black
i can't figure out what what
what the ring
reasoning was i i really can't do it
it's just too much i just can't i'm
trying to be with this is too much
you can't even go to the damn store in
peace
the manifesto left behind by the alleged
gunman suggests he sought out a
community to target authorities say
there is a thread of white supremacy
emerging from the police investigation
these weapons taken from the scene have
racial slurs and hate speech written
across them
eighteen-year-old payton gendron is now
on suicide watch at a detention center
following this court appearance in which
he pleaded not guilty
at the latest news conference
investigators added to their assessment
that this was calculated meticulously
planned and racially motivated they had
more about the suspect's background and
his state of mind
as far as last year it's been put out
there that the state police had
brought this individual in for a mental
health evaluation
he went to the local hospital he was
there for the information we have is
about a day and a half was evaluated and
then released at that point
the new york state governor kathy
hodgsol whose hometown this happens to
be had this for social media companies
and the line between free speech and
hate speech
the social media platforms those
companies will be sitting down and
having
a conversation very soon about are they
doing everything they humanly can
are they putting in place
human intellect as well as algorithms to
identify when this hate speech occurs
and in washington the president added
his disgust
we must all work together to address the
hate
that remains the stain
on the soul of america
our hearts are heavy once again
but a resolve
must never ever waver
in buffalo they want to remember the
victims and not to be remembered as the
scene of another american mass shooting
mark stone sky news in the united states